safer in Chinese Buddhist be clear you
now saying you don't believe that little
things now we want to be polite we this
I was taught very close talk very well I
have a stock not to to behave myself and
more I did actually did most of the time
you won't behead a surprise you to know
and you're saying you don't agree with
his views on tax avoidance does that
mean that you pay more tax than you
legally have to on come on come on come
on please honestly we've got to be this
is the meet the job the media's job is
to ask questions or politicians they ask
questions of me they asked questions of
David Cameron it's right that they do it
is part of what we value about our
country I really want to say that to you
and so you know there's a big story
about tax avoidance we really care about
education as well but they they must be
able to ask the questions and be heard
respectfully now on the on the second
part of your question the answer is I
pay all the taxes the vaio right and
that's my responsibility and the first
question just remind me the first
question I said consistently today what
I said yesterday the different thing
today and yesterday is Lord Fink is
saying what I said about Lord think
because he's big as he's saying hey look
there's sometimes in politics there are
things that are you know not black and
white sometimes there are things that
are rather open and shut when somebody
says I'm gonna sue the Labour leader
because he said I'm engaged in tax
avoidance and the next day says I'm not
gonna sue him but I have engaged in tax
avoidance I'd say that's a pretty
open-and-shut case right